so you're thinking about buying
samsung's new galaxy buds live
for your iphone but the biggest question
is how well do they work
if you don't own an android phone well
i've been using them with my iphone for
a week now so i'll give you not only the
downsides and limitations
but also a surprising benefit that i
found that you gain
if you have an iphone i think for a lot
of ios users the galaxy buds might be a
better buy than the earpods
but not for everyone let's start out
with the benefits the biggest one for me
is the sound quality not only do the
buds live sound better than the regular
airpods but they sound
even better than the pros now is it a
massive difference
no but when i put my airpod pros back
into my ears yesterday after using these
for a week
i could definitely tell the difference
and i missed the rich sound that the
lives give you
with their 12 millimeter drivers they're
also less expensive about 70 dollars
less than the pros
and 30 less than the regular ear pods
with the charging case
but both of those could be purchased a
little bit cheaper now we'll leave links
to the best deals for all three down in
the description
battery life is also better rated at
eight hours for the buds and a total of
28 hours in the case if you have active
noise cancellation disabled
which we'll definitely have to talk
about in just a bit a big benefit for me
is that they don't stick out of your
ears
i love the look it provides and they
don't snag if i'm putting on a helmet a
hat or
anything else really now if you're
somebody that hates having the mini
toothbrush or the hair dryer look
sticking out of your ears
or you just don't want to blend in with
everybody else as earpods
the buds life are great they're also
really comfortable
for me but that will depend on your ears
they don't seal
into your ear canal which helps compared
to the buds plus so they're now about as
comfortable as
earpods i was also pleasantly surprised
by how well they stay in my
ears and if regular airpods fall out for
you these most likely will not
because they do have those wing tips
that you can actually change out to get
a better seal
which of course you can't do with
standard earpods if you have other
reasons for getting them for your iphone
let me know down in the comments section
below now another thing that surprised
me was how
quickly and consistently they connected
to my iphone
the original buds were noticeably worse
than the earpods with that h1 chip
but these are super quick you do miss
out on icloud integration so you'll have
to go into the settings of each ios or
mac device
but the buds live do support multiple
saved connections and they'll
automatically disconnect from my phone
if i select them from my mac's bluetooth
menu just like the airpods
i have to say that it's very interesting
that samsung went the opposite way of
apple
and when they added active noise
cancellation they got rid of the in-ear
seal design
because of this the active noise
cancellation can only remove frequencies
lower than 700 hertz and to be honest
unless you have a constant low noise
without other medium and high frequency
sounds it's kind of pointless it will
definitely get rid of my low
ac vent sound but then my mind starts
focusing in on the higher sounds and
it's even more annoying
and when i was mowing my lawn just a few
days ago it literally
did nothing to enable the active noise
cancellation
so don't buy them for your iphone
instead of airpod pros
if you need active noise cancellation
because of this the lives
are more like the original air pods just
with a little boost
probably added for marketing now there
is a plus sign if you like to listen to
music but also be aware of your
environment these are great for that
just like the regular airpods but with
that you also get that same
big amount of sound leakage if you turn
the volume up now let's talk about
connectivity
software and a bonus for iphone users
i'm so glad that samsung has the galaxy
buds app for iphone and now they keep
updating it i set mine up using the app
and everything connected quickly but it
gave me a prompt to check the bluetooth
settings to make sure that both
bluetooth modes
are connected which they weren't this
part is important as i noticed a glitch
every once in a while
my buds live wouldn't show up in the
audio options but they did show up as
connected in the galaxy buds app i went
into the settings and only the low power
mode was connected so i had to manually
connect to the normal mode
to be able to use them one of these
times the normal mode wouldn't let me
connect
so i actually had to press and reset
them and then reconnect i did figure out
that this was only happening
if i was switching from an android
device to my iphone
and apart from that it would work
perfectly so hopefully they'll fix this
in firmware which you can thankfully
also update using the ios app
and thankfully that app matches most of
the features to android now here are the
things that you'll miss out on
the biggest bummer for me is their
notifications being read out loud
i love having siri read my text with the
earpods you're just
not gonna get that the same thing goes
with bixby on demand
if you have a samsung phone and if you
want to use bixby at all
now you could still use siri by setting
up the customizable touch options to
invoke
your assistant in those touch options
you also won't have the option for one
touch spotify
now an alternative is just setting it
for siri and then asking her to play
spotify or anything else
but that does take a little bit longer
next up is the gaming mode which lowers
latency and
almost matches airpods in ios since the
galaxy buds
also use aac there's no lag when you're
watching
videos but if you're playing a game the
sound will be about a half a second off
compared to about 150 milliseconds so if
you play a lot of games that's one area
where the buds live
won't do as good the last thing that i
missed is the ability to quickly change
bluetooth to my earpods
by pressing on the stem this is helpful
if your phone auto connects to another
bluetooth device but with the buds live
i have to pull out my phone in order to
manually switch it back
now for the one benefit of using the
lives with an
iphone they are surprisingly louder
i would say to get them to match with
the volume on my s20 ultra i have to
lower my iphone to
just over one click lower now they
aren't quiet with the samsung but i do
appreciate having the extra boost when
i'm listening to quieter youtube videos
or podcasts
overall if you don't need hands-free
siri with the text readouts or the low
latency in games i think that the galaxy
buds live
absolutely destroyed the original
earpods now it's a little bit more tough
comparing them to my pros
if you're using an iphone especially if
you want the active noise cancellation
but if you don't need that or the
hands-free siri then the lower cost
and better sounding quality is really
intriguing
and they work surprisingly well with
your iphone
i think that for many iphone users the
buds live
will work quite well and i will
definitely be using mine
a fair bit if you guys want to see my
full real world review
click up there to subscribe and if you
want to see some great galaxy buds
live videos and comparisons to the pros
you guys can check those out right over
there
this one max and i will see you in the
next one